so apparently Mr Beast behind me is an
assassin and if he stabs me with this
rubber knife by the end of the day he
wins 100 Grand in his latest viral stunt
the prolific 24 year old YouTube Star
hired a real assassin to try and murder
him for a hundred thousand dollars this
video is gonna be the craziest video
you've ever seen okay so the video's
title is a little misleading emphasis on
the real assassin not the really killing
me part of that title Mr Beast did not
hire a real assassin to really try and
kill him the Assassin was not really
going to kill Jimmy he does not have a
Death Wish as far as I know but what
would happen legally if he had hired a
real assassin to actually kill him now
if you're one of the 12 people who
haven't seen Mr BEAST's video here's a
quick summary over the course of 10
hours Mr Beast engages in a very
expensive game of cat and mouse to elude
his would-be fake assassin across five
different locations inside this car's
backpack is not only 100 Grand but also
a Tracker giving him my real-time
location among Mr Beast exorbitant
expenditures include getting a tank to
run over the Assassin's Car checking
into every single room in a hotel and
filling them with directions using
Lamborghini and helicopter to escape
blowing up a real bank and building his
own carnival at the end of the video Mr
Beast did give his opponent a sporting
Chance by faking an ankle injury at the
carnival to see if the Assassin would
still stab him got all this for a broken
ankle huh yeah
yeah I don't know about that
[Music]
a fake knife but Mr Beast is a man of
his word and paid the hundred thousand
dollar Bounty here's their hundred
thousand dollars this means a lot to me
and my family thank you now of course
this was all just a very expensive and
entertaining stunt but it does raise an
interesting legal issue is it a crime to
actually take a hit out against yourself
and you'd be surprised or maybe not
surprised how often this comes up on
Reddit so let's Dive Right In is it
illegal for Mr Beast to actually pay
someone to kill him short answer yes
longer answer absolutely it's 100 a
crime but the question of which laws
would have been broken by Mr Beast and
his hired assassin is a more interesting
question I did once try to kill the
world's greatest lover
but then I realized there are laws
against suicide so let's start with the
laws against suicide now the former
mayor of Springfield is partially right
in British common law suicide used to be
a felony well attempted suicide was a
misdemeanor which sort of makes no sense
at all but historically those who
successfully took their own lives would
be buried in a public Highway with a
stake driven through their body and by
forfeiture would surrender the remaining
possessions to the king yikes but in the
United States suicide is no longer
considered a statutory crime but some
states still criminalize an unsuccessful
attempt in 2018 Maryland made news after
a 56-year-old man pleaded guilty to one
charge of attempted suicide and was
sentenced to a three-year suspended jail
sentence and two years of probation
Maryland recognizes a common law crime
like attempted suicide that have no
specific penalty leaving it up to the
judge to decide the punishment and
according to the prosecutor this charge
was quote not something I've seen before
and not something he'd pursue in the
future quote it's not like we're trying
to put this guy in jail or anything
We're just trying to get him into a
mental health treatment now naturally
critics felt that giving a mentally ill
man a criminal record under the guise of
helping him wasn't use of prosecutorial
discretion but that's first party
suicide and as far as I can tell from Mr
BEAST's video he did not wish to take
his own life so he hired someone else
theoretically and states have generally
made it a crime to help people end their
own lives even with the deceased consent
this includes both physician-assisted
suicide in which a doctor administers a
lethal dose of medication as well as
assisted suicide outside of the medical
context and only 10 states and the
District of Columbia allow for
physician-assisted suicide and many of
the states have strict requirements and
procedures that must be followed for the
doctor to avoid homicide charges such as
requiring the patient to be a state
resident have fewer than six months to
live and be given many opportunities to
change their mind to legally end a
person's life without jumping through
any Hoops you'd have to become a police
officer
but outside of these jurisdictions
individuals who end another person's
life will face criminal charges even if
done with the deceased permission of
course many people remember the trials
of Dr Kevorkian who helped with many
instances of physician-assisted suicide
and in January 2023 an elderly woman was
arrested for shooting her terminally ill
husband at the hospital as part of a
murder suicide pact they made weeks
prior although she could have been
indicted for Murder She was hit with
lesser charges of assisting self-murder
slash manslaughter and aggravated
assault of a law enforcement officer but
of course suicide is one thing hiring a
contract killer to kill anyone including
yourself is a completely different
matter legal eagle breaking news it is
illegal to murder people but if you're
learning this for the first time you
probably need to hire a lawyer like
yesterday and since it's a crime to
murder people it's also illegal to hire
someone to commit murder the crime of
contract killing AKA murder For Hire
occurs when one party hires another to
kill a targeted individual or group of
people in exchange for some pecuniary
benefit however any agreement to commit
murder would be an illegal contract and
therefore not legally enforceable so if
someone Welches on your murder contract
don't expect a court to help you get
your money back and typically this is
charged as a state crime though
penalties vary by jurisdiction in
Florida where this happens just as often
as you'd think the higher it faces a
life sentence if the victim is actually
killed and the maximum 20 years of the
victim is injured but not killed and if
the murder plot is formed but the victim
isn't injured or killed the potential
sentence is about 10 years and as you
may recall Joe Exotic AKA The Tiger King
is currently serving a 21-year prison
sentence for trying to hire two
different men one of whom was an
undercover FBI agent to kill his Nemesis
and animal rights activist Carol Baskin
and here Federal's jurisdiction was
established because the scheme involved
Interstate travel in Commerce
specifically Joe Exotic gave the first
Hitman three thousand dollars to travel
from Oklahoma to South Carolina and then
to Dallas in furtherance of the murder
plot and murder for higher plots
typically involve killing a third party
but what happens if the intended victim
is yourself and while hiring an assassin
to take out yourself doesn't happen in
real life that much if you search
suicide by Hitman on IMDb you'll see
nearly two dozen movies and TV shows
using this Trope but most famously this
plot line takes center stage in the
criminally underrated bulworth in this
1998 political satire Warren Beatty
plays a depressed U.S senator who
decides to end his life then takes out a
10 million dollar life insurance policy
naming his daughter as the beneficiary
knowing that suicide would avoid the
policy the senator then hires a Hitman
to kill him and of course that's also
the plot to the Chevy Chase movie Fletch
I'm sure all the kids watching Mr Beast
remember Fletch now how long have you
had these pains Mr Barber now that's
Babar
two B's
1B p-i-b-a-r that's two yeah but not
right next to each other I thought
that's what you meant right
okay you know it's a good movie uh and
that's actually not too far off from
what actually happened in South Carolina
very recently in real life Alec Murdoch
uh who in March of 2023 was found guilty
in the double homicide of his wife and
son was previously caught up in a failed
suicide for higher scheme to have his
cousin Eddie shoot him to death and in
that case of Life imitating art Murdoch
arranged for his own failed murder so
his son Buster could like bulworth
collect on the 10 million dollar life
insurance policy except when Cousin
Eddie tried to shoot Murdoch the bullet
only grazed his head in 2021 the grand
jury indicted the cousins for their
suicide for higher scheme Cousin Eddie
was charged with it assisted suicide
assault and battery of a high aggravated
nature appointing and presenting a
firearm insurance fraud and conspiracy
to commit insurance fraud Murdoch was
charged with insurance fraud conspiracy
to commit insurance fraud and filing a
false police report notably Murdoch was
not charged with murder For Hire or with
any crime related to the actual suicide
For Hire just the crimes surrounding the
scheme like insurance fraud and that's
how the state of Utah handled a similar
suicide for higher case in 2018 22 year
old Eric bedola while claiming to be a
19 year old woman slash his ex-fiancee
entered into an agreement online with a
Hitman to kill bedola in exchange for
five thousand dollars The Hitman was
actually a detective that happens a lot
in these kinds of cases The Hitman that
you're talking to is you know probably a
cop or an FBI agent but pedola was
promptly arrested and charged with first
degree felony criminal solicitation and
second-degree felony obstruction of
justice like Murdoch the state did not
charge medulla for the actual suicide
For Hire plot just the ancillary crimes
but that brings us to the main question
what would happen if Mr Beast did hire
an assassin to kill him what were the
legal consequences be for Jimmy and his
whole team if everything in the video
wasn't actually a stunt but actually
happened in real life well for starters
Mr Beast is a resident of North Carolina
so that state law controls and North
Carolina does Outlaw murder for higher
schemes not surprising and interestingly
North Carolina has no specific statute
outlining suicide for hire and we
couldn't find any example of the
prosecution in that state their
terminally ill patients do have a right
to have their medical Representatives
honor a patient's decision to withdraw
or withhold life-sustaining measures
under North Carolina General article 23.
but whether you call it a murder For
Hire or suicide For Hire Mr Beast Antics
would likely still be classified as an
illegal contract killing how did Jimmy
find an assassin for this anyway I found
Jimmy he didn't find me the fact doesn't
change just because Mr B's contract
involves an elaborate game of cat and
mouse so I've seen the other guys that
chase Jimmy he's going to be ready there
for us so you can point and laugh and
call us nerds well that ain't gonna
happen this time a few moments later
listen to this real quick
that's my door to my getaway vehicle
later nerd
just ninja flipped out of here again and
if Mr Beast or his associates engaged in
any interstate commerce or
Communications or travel and connection
with the scheme from you know renting
tanks to hiring actors to fill up the
hotel well that murder For Hire plot is
probably now a federal crime as well now
typically as you saw in the Murdoch in
bedola cases the individuals who take
out a contract against themselves are
not charged with the actual suicide for
higher plot but that doesn't mean that
they couldn't be it's still the same
crime and similarly Mr Beast could
theoretically be charged with conspiracy
to off himself conspiracy is an
agreement between two or more people to
commit an illegal act along with an
intent to achieve the agreement's goal
and generally at least one over an act
in furtherance of that illegal goal it's
illegal to pay someone to kill someone
and if you're doing the paying you are
engaged in a conspiracy even when the
target is yourself and I'd feel bad for
anyone on Mr B's team who also helped
out in the process of intending to off
the main start because anyone else
involved in the murder For Hire plot
even if you just take a small overt act
in further they're into the conspiracy
well you are screwed every time someone
helped out in this entire scheme well
they're probably on the hook too I'm I'm
looking at you Chris are you telling me
to rob a bank yeah actually I am and
every time Mr Beast asks someone to
commit a crime on his behalf uh well
that's probably criminal solicitation
and when Mr Beast encourages a person to
commit a crime and that person does
commit that crime well that's probably
aiding and abetting as well Chris are
you in the tank yeah where did we get a
tank from they're inside the warehouse
you know what to do Roger that rubber
suits going dark destroy the car
kidding me they ran over our car with a
tank I ran over your car with a tank
though of course the bank explosion here
was actually done with the bank's
consent because it was said to be
demolished anyway but that's a good
thing because otherwise Mr Beast would
be facing some light terrorism charges
under 18 USC 844. oh and in such a case
the death penalty is on the table if
anyone is killed in the attack for
example in 2020 26 year old Jerry Drake
Varnell was convicted under these
statutes for plotting with an undercover
FBI agent to blow up an Oklahoma City
Bank in 2017 the then 23 year old
Varnell drove a van loaded with what he
thought was an active bomb to the bank
and attempted to detonate the fake
device with his cell phone Varnell was
sentenced to 25 years in prison for his
unsuccessful attempt now thankfully Mr
BEAST's whole video was just an
entertaining stunt that everyone was in
on and there was no illegal aim at the
end of this contract because if it
wasn't Mr Beast and his friends would be
going to jail for a very very long time
though I imagine spending time in prison
would only make Mr B's YouTube
viewership go even higher
oh uh he's actually done that
now between driving a Lambo a tank and a
helicopter Mr Beast carbon footprint is
well not small now carbon offsets could
be a great option but most of the
current Marketplace enables and even
incentivizes scams to the point that
they're nothing more than green washing
on average but today's sponsor Ren
reached out and created a system that
makes carbon offsets actually work
whether you're Mr Beast or just trying
to do your part for the environment now
my friend Sam over at Wendover
Productions a jet lag grilled their CEO
and put them through their Paces he's
convinced that Ren is as good as it gets
when it comes to carbon offsetting now
carbon offsetting is only as good as the
accuracy of the project evaluations Ren
checks hundreds of tiny details to
verify that each project is actually
going to do what it says and it's an
ongoing process once the project
actually starts too they only have seven
active projects so they put a ton of
focus into each one and they only sell
offsets to a combined portfolio of all
of their projects that way they reduce
the risk and build in a margin for air
if one of the projects falls short so if
you want to be genuinely as sure as
possible that you're actually offsetting
the emissions from taking a flight or
driving around town Wren is the place to
go that'll be what I'm using going
forward for both my personal and
business carbon offsetting and I think
you should too they make it super simple
to calculate your estimated personal
carbon footprint and give personalized
suggestions on how to reduce it then for
anything else you can set up a monthly
offset so you can reduce your personal
contribution to the climate crisis doing
this probably costs a lot less than you
think and it's even less considering
that if you click on the button that's
on screen right now or down in the
description they'll pay to offset the
first month of emissions for the first
100 people to sign up so if you'd like
to reduce your carbon footprint the most
effective way possible click on the link
below and after that click on this box
over here for more legal eagle or I'll
see you in court